hey Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie
[Music]
hi Ken
hi Ken there's no place like Barbie land
there's no place
the new trailer for Barbie dropped
Tuesday now people on social media are
theorizing that the plot of the Greta
Gerwig flick might mirror The Wizard of
Oz expect the unexpected whatever you're
thinking it's not it's not that it's not
what you think it is
unless it is and then you know what it
is and then it but but I don't think
that's what you think it is what is it
wait what are we talking about the
Barbie movie oh yeah
I'm excited are you that's that's all I
can say okay
otherwise Mattel will come in and box me
up the cast has stayed tight-lipped
about the story's premise who are you
playing I can't tell you I feel like the
less I tell you the better but Tick Tock
Creator cat Quinn went viral on Tuesday
with her Theory pointing out a few
subtle nods to the 1939 classic in the
trailer starting with Margot Robbie's
pink gingham dress which looks like a
modern Twist on Dorothy's signature look
I am Dorothy
the small and meek and I'm happy other
people are excited I thought it'd be
more like next year people would start
you know dressing like Barbie and Ken
for Halloween so
um I think we're all a little taken back
by the response but really really
thrilled by it Margo's a real life
Barbie she is one of the best people I
think I've ever met and worked with she
looks like a Barbie she is a Barbie like
the casting is there honey then there's
this isn't just as fast
as hell rewind slow down now pause right
there you'll see movie posters of
Dorothy the Tin Man and the lion outside
of the movie theater I haven't any
courage at all
I even scam myself
and the Marquee features the iconic
film's title it feels like anything that
happens gets a huge reaction uh for
Bobby's if you look closely you'll also
notice the road Barbie drives down is a
pink brick road a Twist on the yellow
brick road
[Music]
I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them and
while we'll just have to wait and see if
Barbie clicks her heels three times to
return home we do know we can expect to
see lots of Abs if I wasn't severely
injured I would beat you off right now
Ken I'll be talking with you any day Ken
who worked out harder definitely Ryan
I'm gonna 100 he's he's definitely like
a gym in the morning gym after work kind
of guy I'm like I I respect it I respect
it I'm gonna have some soda I can't wait
for people to see them and the cast has
teased that the audience has a lot to
look forward to it is brilliant
intelligent I think there are many
prolific things that she says and to
have something with that storyline in
that dialogue set with the backdrop of
the most campy Barbie movie you have
ever seen I mean it just flips the whole
genre on its head I might still
why because we're
just working what
they're not sure I feel like every
little piece of news that comes out to
tease people everyone just gets
progressively more confused and curious
as to what this movie is and I kind of
like that I feel like um I feel like
July of next year when it comes people
are going to be really really surprised
foreign